you're a gamer right yeah what do you
play I mean I play fortnight right now
but I used to play Counter Strike oh wow
the only person playing for you what do
you want to school you want me to scream
every night oh that's so you will cuz I
suck at 4 at night right now yeah the
building part and then also the fact
that you have to you have to aim
correctly on sniping where you have to
like time you have to time it where it's
like all right this person might be
moving to this place and I need to aim a
little bit above because not like if
they're getting in your crosshairs
you're you're getting that snipe yeah
you got to make sure like how far away
you are and everything well it's like
destiny the reason why I stopped playing
destiny was because of PvP and because
every time I die scream where I get
angry I throw controllers help me to you
know I mean or if my teammates my fire
team isn't doing what I want them to do
you know they we'd there's fights like
what are you doing that's not done ye
behind that wall
we're over here shooting I told you to
be here oh I don't know I just thought
that I could do a side thing I sneaked
away no like a stick around and Surprise
them I'm like you're not even that good
so you would have died anyway you know I
mean it's that kind of thing so yeah I
do many liabilities there but no do when
you here's another thing I don't like
about fortnight is when you die they
take your [ __ ] oh you mean you they take
the stuff that you picked up in the game
yeah yeah but I mean it's a match you
don't get it every time but imagine this
imagine if you died in real life and
then people sort of today took your
[ __ ] DJ spinning to spinning things
that you do see what's wrong I never I
never thought about it like that but
yeah yeah that's yours yeah that was
mine they don't take mine ok so what
else you see you only play like PvP
stuff yeah you're not a fallout you
don't like Bethesda stuff like RPGs
single-player I'm not really
I used to on Dreamcast I forgot the game
that I play yeah way back dreams can say
good yeah sangmoo no it was this one
where was like this like you could play
as four characters and they had these
weird arms that you could like throw
elemental things
oh yeah it's remember that I don't
remember was that an art role-playing
game yeah well but you know what and
dude I broke so many could that's why I
don't play role-playing games because
I broke so many controllers because when
you're sitting there and you can't like
you can't hurt them
you have to like wait your turn for them
not so well you're set okay those are
turn-based role-playing games okay my
bad well Final Fantasy in death app is
probably a trivet ace yeah those where
you you you attack then you have to wait
for everyone at that time yeah there's
your turn again
yeah but the RPGs that I play now like
the ones that Bethesda do are like real
time RPGs right what is that so
basically it's open world okay you when
you shoot a gun like fortnight you shoot
somebody
yeah but obviously not a real person by
character in the game right and I came
like fallout for instance you can build
a home you know like you can use build a
beautiful home with defenses uh-huh you
gonna have a dog you can go out you
don't have to kill things you can just
pick things up like I need to go get
wood and also this you know like
detergent yeah but other other people
are in this world trying to shoot you
know no it's just no it's open notes
it's it's a single-player and then you
go in and you fight mutants you fight
other people like to come home - no
that's not what it is I like GTA it's
kind of in many ways in GTA but GTA you
can't okay
eta it's like GTA but you can't desert
like RP the Bethesda game I'm talking
about yeah if you can design wear
whatever you want to wear design the
facial structure the ethnicity of your
person height all that stuff yeah okay
and then also you can wear clothing that
you want to wear yeah
although GT has that you can go to a
clothing store but the options are
limited yeah in RPGs now especially the
Bethesda ones which aren't talking about
Elder Scrolls Skyrim or the Fallout
series yeah and then you can on the maps
are gigantic and it's just a lot of fun
man I mean I was going to get fallout
for Xbox and then I never did it because
I just I watched the the trailer and I
just didn't do it but I'll do it for you
no you know the deal for me I will but
you're saying it's good oh well I mean
like Fox I don't know anyone that played
fallout
okay it's like a Kenny I might not go to
the movie now because I got the internal
thing just add me Sally alright thing is
is that but how about this I'll do the
new fallout 76 is coming out in November
and it is a PvP multiplayer the
multiplayer in it everyone's doing
battle royale it's the new thing it's
the new thing right
so he'll is doing one probably it's got
it you can do it sites got all this
elements of fallout where you
single-player you can build a house you
can go out there's storylines missions
and stuff that you can do on your own
yeah but then you can also do things
with other people but what I would do if
I that's awesome
what I would do if I were you you have
an xbox one I've both ps4 I think you do
I think what are you that DJ let me plan
just don't know they sent it to me
Xbox one yeah you get free [ __ ] yeah as
a DJ he's famous that's why I has
popular because I can get so much [ __ ]
I'm gonna pay for it what do you buy
these shoes do this for me or get the
fallout 4 get fallout 4 okay then buy
this free [ __ ] I bought the Hat though
yeah I bought this made warned wait wait
wait wait you play on xbox yeah but I
want you to get fallout 4 right I want
you to I want you to play it I will know
I'm being real I will start a character
which it will play it and see how can we
do submissions together no we can't do
it if all four because they don't have
that yet in November but that's what I
want to see I want you to play you want
used to it get used to an if you don't
even like the world then [ __ ] it what
anyone do it I want to waste my time
okay because when I play some file out
somebody say you're plating right now
listen to me right now I'm gonna be full
in it okay okay
[Music]